hey 42 here the voynich manuscript is
without a doubt
one of the most mysterious inexplicable
and downright intriguing objects on
planet earth today
it has been called a message from god a
hoax an elaborate secret code
the product of mental illness a treatise
written in a lost
language a guide to an alien world
or simply the notebook of an eccentric
scientist
written in his own indecipherable
shorthand
since it came to the attention of the
public a little more than a hundred
years ago
it has been served as the inspiration
for a plethora of novels a classical
music album
several works of art and at least one tv
episode
it's even appeared as an easter egg
hidden away in more than one
popular video game franchise and yet
this strange artifact whose story spans
centuries and touches the lives of some
of history's most
colourful characters is nothing more
than a simple book
about the size of a modern paperback if
you were to visit yale's beineckey rare
book and manuscript library where the
voynich manuscript resides today
and leaf through its 240-yard vellum
pages you would find a curious flowing
script
in likely faded browning surrounded on
almost every page
by weird and wonderful painted images
depicting people
plants animals astrological diagrams
curious contraptions maps to strange
lands
and much more the odd little book is
split into six distinct sections
botanical astrological balneological
which relates to medicinal
springs cosmological pharmaceutical
and recipes all of this sounds
interesting enough so far
but alone it doesn't explain why the
voynich manuscript has attained the
status
of a true enigma nor does the fact that
it's over 600 years old
there are plenty of older books out
there tucked away on dusty bookshelves
and great libraries across the world
and nobody's fought to make music about
any of those
no what makes the voynich manuscript so
special
is much simpler than all of that nobody
alive
has ever been able to read it or should
i say
nobody alive has ever been able to
understand it
now you may not be able to read the
voynich manuscript but
you can enjoy thousands of other books
with today's sponsor
blinkist it probably wouldn't surprise
you if i told you there's
little i love more than reading
non-fiction books
but these days i rarely get the time i'm
sure you're in the same boat
well i've been trying out blinkist and
it's been a
game changer for my daily routine i
listen to a blink whilst i'm having my
breakfast every morning
and by the time i've junk my last sip of
coffee i've learned new fascinating
knowledge and
musings from the world's best authors
and thinkers
blinkist condenses insights from the top
3 000
plus non-fiction books into byte size
15 minute listens and if you want to
dive deeper
premium members get a whopping 65
percent of full-length audio books that
you can listen to
right in the blinkist app you can use
blinkist to save
time and money and learn new things
faster than ever before
you can use it for self-improvement get
parenting advice
or learn how to improve your daily
workflow even further
with blinks such as atomic habits by
james clear
personally i would recommend 21 lessons
for the 21st century
by yuval noah harari i've always enjoyed
his previous books and
this one is a fascinating insight into
what the future might hold for us
as a species the first 100 people to
visit my unique link below
are going to get unlimited access for
one week to try it out
completely free and you can cancel at
any time during that period
but if you just can't get enough then
through my link
you'll also get 25 off if you want the
full membership
despite the painstaking attentions of
master cryptographers
diligent language experts learned art
historians
and a whole cadre of internet sleuths
not
one person has ever been able to make
sense
of a single word written within the
voynich manuscripts pages
and its strange alphabet has never been
seen
anywhere else in the world and then
there are those painted images i
mentioned
whilst the people look familiar enough
most of them are rendered completely
naked and could stand to lose a pound or
two
the plants are much less easily
identified
not a single one of them bears more than
a passing resemblance
to any of the species found here on
earth
exactly who wrote the voynich manuscript
in which language and
for what reason is completely unknown
and just what the hell it's all supposed
to mean
is a question that has captivated
imaginations
across the world ever since the book was
uncovered
by the man it's now named after wilfred
vainage voynich was born in november
to polish parents in the city of telstra
which was part of the russian empire at
the time
and can be found today in lithuania he
was something of a free spirit in his
younger days
getting himself arrested in his early
twenties thanks to his membership of the
social revolutionary organization
known as the proletariat which
ultimately led to his imprisonment
in her cuts siberia a place famous today
for its historic town center
and for being abysmally difficult to
defend in risk
voynich was a resourceful man and he
managed to escape
before his five-year sentence was up
keen to put some distance between
himself and his turbulent past
he made his way to hamburg where he
traded his last good waistcoat
and a rather dashing pair of glasses for
a ticket on a ship
bound for england voynich dabbled in a
little more revolutionary work over the
next few years from his new home in
london
but perhaps deciding he'd had enough of
being shot at and stabbed
and no doubt growing complacent on a
steady diet of tea
crumpet and remarkably orderly queuing
he finally decided to leave his wild
days behind him
a highly educated man who is said to
have spoken 18 languages
he decided to settle down and get
himself a real job as an antiquarian
bookseller
voynich also found love in london
marrying another former revolutionary
called
ethel boole author of multi-million
selling novel
the gadfly and daughter of george bull
whose
boolean logic is credited with having
laid the foundations
for the information age i've said it
before
and i'll say it again all the famous
people in the past knew each other
it was in 1912 that voynich made the
discovery
which he is known for today whilst
visiting the villa mondragoni which lies
about 20 kilometers outside of rome
villa mandragone was owned by a group of
jesuits at the time of voynich's visit
and despite their grand and prestigious
setup the imposing villa montragoni was
the site where the gregorian calendar
was first developed
it turned out that the jesuits were a
little strapped for cash
voynich was more than happy to line
their pockets in return for a chance to
go home
with a few of the rare manuscripts
stored in the villas library
amongst the 30 items he purchased that
day was the book
now known as define it manuscript
it was immediately clear to wilfred
voynich that this latest addition to his
collection
was old and more than a little strange
in the hundred or so years since he came
into possession of this
now legendary artifact many people
including voynich himself
have attempted to piece together the
manuscript's origins
its first known owner is thought to have
been rudolf ii
or to give him his full title rudolf ii
holy roman emperor
king of hungary and croatia king of
bohemia
and archduke of austria i think i'll
stick with rudy
frequent viewers of this channel will be
delighted to hear that rudy was a member
of the infamous house of habsburg
inbreeder's extraordinaire and that yes
he did indeed have a chin like a
sledgehammer
rudy is thought to have come into
possession of the voynich manuscript
towards the end of the 16th century
when it was already some 200 years old
and he is said to have been so intrigued
by its
curious content that he bought it from
the previous owner
for the princely sum or should that be
multiple kingly sum
of 600 venetian duck hats
that's a little more than two kilograms
of solid
gold not bad for a tatty old book king
rudy was a
character to say the least he's known to
have kept a lion and the tiger as part
of his prized royal menagerie
and he was so fond of the beasts that
they were allowed to roam freely around
his home
castle prague yeah that went about as
well as you might expect
but rudy wasn't a bad guy and he was
more than happy to pay compensation to
the
survivors of the unsurprisingly frequent
attacks
and playful maulings his favorite pets
dished out or more commonly to the
deceased's
grieving and no doubt a recoverably
traumatized family
he was also a devoted alchemist and
pursued a lifelong quest
to get his hands on the philosopher's
stone
tragically unaware as he was that said
mythical object
was hidden under a trap door guarded by
a free-headed dog
at hogwarts all along rudy was also keen
on astrology
and even commissioned a personal
horoscope from french astrologer
nachodarmus
armed with this priceless insight into
his own future
you'd think rudy would have been
prepared when his own brother
moved against him to take the throne
some years later
but apparently not king rudolf ii
died nine months later stripped of all
his powers
and the mysterious book he paid a
literal king's ransom for
was passed to his personal doctor yakko
bus of teppence
whose signature so faded with age it's
only visible under
ultraviolet light can still be found
hidden
within the voynich manuscripts pages
today
from yakibus the manuscript made us into
the hands of george baresh
a czech alchemist who would spend the
next 20 years of his life
attempting to unearth its secrets
chipping away at the mystery in vain
until the day he died baresh bequeathed
the manuscript to a trusted friend in
his will
who in turn passed a book onto his
mentor the celebrated 17th century
scientist
afrancius kircher known as the master of
a hundred
arts it seemed like a smart move
kercher was a learned man he had
recently shot to fame as the first
person to decipher egyptian
hieroglyphics
who better to uncover the secrets of an
unreadable manuscript
the plan did have one slight flaw though
despite his claims kercher had not in
fact deciphered egyptian hieroglyphics
at
all and the majority of his assumptions
and translations
were later found to be completely false
make that master of 99 arts then
the voynich manuscript seems to have
proven impenetrable to kircher
and here it disappeared back into
relative obscurity
stashed away in the library of colegio
romano
where kercher worked the manuscript
was to remain there no doubt gathering a
thick layer of dust
for more than 200 years until rome was
captured by victor emmanuel ii
one-time king of sardinia and eventual
king of italy
who promptly confiscated the collegiate
romano's library
luckily the college's rector at the time
managed to rescue some of the library's
most important books
including the voynich manuscript
transferring the lot
to the villa manjagoni where as we've
seen
voynich would be along to find it some
46 years later
now run a simple google search and you'd
be forgiven for thinking
the voynich manuscript had been solved
half a hundred times there are endless
articles and a good dose of youtube
videos
even documentaries out there claiming
the 600 year mystery has
finally been defeated but every time
some young hopeful comes up with a new
and promising theory
the scientific community stoically steps
up to the scholarly plate
and bats it out of the park the very
first such claim was put forward by
william newbold
a professor of philosophy at the
university of pennsylvania and a
cryptography enthusiast
who was hired by voynich himself to
unlock the secrets of his prized
possession
newbold research led him to the
conclusion that the writings within the
manuscript
was in fact meaningless but
that a secret code based on ancient
greek shorthand
and visible only with the use of a
magnifying glass had been hidden within
the letters themselves
disguised as natural patterns within the
ink
ingenious newbold claims to have
translated entire paragraphs of the text
using the code
which reveals the author to be none
other than english polymath and
franciscan freya
roger bacon this theory has
unfortunately been thoroughly debunked
it turns out those secret markings
cleverly disguised as patterns within
the ink were
in fact yeah just naturally occurring
patterns within the
ink who'd have thought it still the idea
that the voynich manuscript is some kind
of
highly elaborate cipher persists and
some of the greatest code breakers to
have
ever lived and breathed have had a crack
at solving it
hoping to uncover some long-lost secret
hidden within its pages perhaps the most
prominent is william f
friedman considered by some to be the
greatest cryptologist of the modern age
friedman was a brilliant man his team
broke japan's cipher codenamed purple
during the second world war and he was
instrumental in the founding of the nsa
in the us where he was installed as its
first chief
cryptologist friedman was so intrigued
by the voynich manuscript that he put
together a crack team of cryptologists
to unlock his secrets
this pet project spanned four decades of
friedman's life
but despite all his brilliance and
dedication
he eventually concluded that solving the
voynich manuscript
was in fact impossible
suggesting it was written in a made-up
language
friedman isn't the only one to conclude
that the manuscript can't be solved for
the simple reason that
there's nothing to solve that we can't
extract any meaning from its strange
pages because
there was no meaning there in the first
place just a lot of
rather pretty gibberish some proponents
of this theory believe that voynich
himself
is behind the fabrication after all a
lost text of links to the likes of
francis bacon would likely be worth a
fortune
something an antique book dealer would
know better than anyone
on the face of it it's quite a
compelling argument
voynich had a clear motive as well as
the know-how to pull it off
and make it look good but the voynich
manuscript isn't just
good it's perfect
and if it really is a hoax it's one of
the most elaborate
ever conceived for a start the
manuscripts pages have been radiocarbon
dated to between 1404
and 1438 the idea that voynich might
have been able to get his hands on
240 untouched sheets of 500 year old
vellum
made from calfskin in 1912
to turn into a book is near
inconceivable
and considering radiocarbon dating
wasn't developed until the late 1940s
long after voynich first publicized his
find
it's difficult to see why he would have
bothered trying to source such an old
material to write on in the first place
the inks and paints using the manuscript
also exactly match those used
in early 15th century europe something
else we've been able to prove
only with modern techniques and the same
attention to detail seems to have been
paid in the book's language
too which demonstrates statistical
features we would expect to see
in real natural language features we
also didn't understand back in 1912.
wilfred voynich may have had the motive
but he would have needed to be in the
possession of the predictive powers of
notre dame
himself to have avoided all yet to be
discovered scientific traps that lay
waiting to reveal any deception on his
part
decades later the voynich manuscript
it seems is very much the genuine
article and to this day professionals
and amateurs alike
continue to dedicate countless hours
trying to finally
solve its many mysteries and many claim
to have solved it once and for all
even presenting examples of fully
translated pages
but there's always the inherent issue of
how can we trust the veracity of a
translation
when the only person in the world who
claims it's correct
is the translator himself the truth is
so far every attempt that decoding it
has either been declared to be false by
an independent body
or not peer-reviewed at all and
thus no more than an unverified
hypothesis
in 2016 we even let an ai have a crack
at it
completely in vain and in some ways
perhaps that's for the best whilst the
true
meaning behind the unknown text remains
a mystery
the voynich manuscript will continue to
stimulate our collective
sense of wonder and illicit excited
scholarly debate the moment we figure
out that it's actually the world's most
ancient
and vulgar collection of that's what she
said jokes
the charming spell will be broken thanks
for watching
thanks again to blinkist for sponsoring
this video don't forget to check it out
using the link in the description